Bashkim për balimi.
Kështu është emërtuar sala këresore e muzell.
Ajo për bët nga piktura murale që rëfejnë historinë njëzët e pes vjeqare të Skënderbejl.
Në huje të salës janë të ekspozuara du këmbane originale të shëjkullit katërmbëdhjedh.
Pas beteje së nishit më tre nëtërë 1923, Skënderbejl bashk me treqinë Dibran, këthejët në kruj,
kumë njëzëtë të tëtë në nëtërë 1423, gre flamurë në kuqë me shipponën du krenare.
Në pikturë përraqitëtë të heroju në komëtari përullur paratëvamës,
si edhe një pjes të fjalimit që a imbajti para populi të krujës.
Lirin nukua sola onë, a të gjeta mes jushë.
Në lejhë u vendos unifikimi vendit në në udhejë që në Skënderbejl.
Në këtë salë janë përraqitur edhe flamu të gjashë principatave këresore,
kastriotëve, skuraive, dukagjinazve, aranitazve, muzakaive dhe topiaive.
Piktura murale në qëndërë të kësaj salë, paraqit fragmenten dhe luftrat shqiptar Osmanë.
Kjo pikturë qështë me e madhja në vendë, redh 108 m4 dhe përmban 300 figurina.
Autori kësaj vej për madhështore vështë pikturi Naji Bakali,
i cili punoj njëmbëdhjetë muaj e gjusëm për të realizuar a të.
Po këtuja në ekspuzuar shpata dhe për krenarja e Skëndërbeu,
originalet e të cilave në doden në muzeun historik të artit në Vjen.
Për njëzëtë e pes vjetë Skëndërbeu jë vjëlojmë bë njëzëtë beteja.
Më të spikaturat janë tre rethimet e krujes 1450, 1466, 1467,
beteja e torviolit mënjë 1424, albulenës mënjë 1457
dhe Vaikalit mënjë 1465.
Në këtë salë është vendosu një tabloqë që paraqet mëmentet e fundi të jetë se herojtë.
A tuj paraqetën ba shkluftare të përlodur, për të ba shkorë.
Skëndërbeu vë diqë në lejhë më shtatëm bëdhjet janar 1467.
Për shkakë të rezistencës aktive ndaj sundimit Osman,
a izuri vendin mëtërë ndësishem në historin e Shqipëris, du gëubër heroju në komtar.
Në ala bastër jan paraqitur disa nga kalat kresore të mesjetës,
kalaja e Rodonit, kalaja e Beratit, kalaja e Petrelës dhe kalaja e Krujës.
Dërsa në harf tregot një shtrije mëj gjerë fortifikimëve.
Gravura të përshkrojnë momente të betejeve të zhvillura.